balcon
renversement des vagues
ceux
payer
Je ne peux pas, mes deux sont là, c'est ma femme
est mort Ma tension artérielle a augmenté elle 10
passé des jours à l'hôpital est décédé
fils enterré, il ne s'en est pas occupé
la toxicomanie c'est pareil
toutes sortes de pilules sont morts à 46 ans, il était
enterré Eh bien, je ne vais nulle part
comprends déjà ce qui n'arrivera pas aussi
Je pense que je n'irai plus nulle part
pendant des années
[musique]
j'utilise des protections
je vais jusqu'à ça
ici est protégé et peut-être même aller se coucher
sur ça
remplir parce qu'une vague peut faire tomber
frapper le mur je ne suis pas stupide non plus
Humain
[musique]
sortons comme si tu étais un communicant
est venu voir quelque chose
précipité et donc les hauts de Pouchkine
détourne de ces pensées qui
constamment présent chez une personne
L'Ukraine, qu'est-ce qui se passe avec le peuple, c'est pourquoi il n'y a pas
la paix c'est dur c'est dur
et c'est un peu gênant
dit oui dans ces moments-là peut-être et
une telle bible il est temps de lire un travail
Maintenant, j'ai même commencé à lire la Bible à cause de
le fait que
commencé à prendre
nous avons aussi un animal de compagnie